Joe Biden gave a Thanksgiving
Proclamation this year as the presidents
usually do but he left an important
person out of it that would be God by my
count only two presidents in American
history ever have given a Thanksgiving
Proclamation that omitted God to whom we
owe thanks that would be Joe Biden and
Barack Obama they're the only two what
does this mean does this mean that it's
just the Democrats have always been the
part
against God well implicitly perhaps but
they at least would pay lip service to
God Jimmy Carter certainly acknowledged
God and His Thanksgiving proclamations
Bill Clinton acknowledged God in his
Thanksgiving proclamations this is a new
thing for Democrat presidents it's Obama
and then Biden Biden being Barack
Obama's third term what does that mean
it means that liberalism today is
anti-christian